concerts are cancelled
a lot of them with large gatherings
limited or prohibited due to the
coronavirus
many artists are now performing online
for free
this change has upended the live music
business
the industry was on track to generate
nearly 30 billion dollars this year
before the pandemic hit now analysts
project a 75
drop in global revenue down to 6.5
billion dollars with the industry in
crisis
artists and producers are re-imagining
concerts but without crowds
and some of these new shows are already
attracting millions of fans globally
going to a concert and being in a big
crowd that's one live experience
but doesn't mean that it's the only live
experience
now the question is whether they'll also
be able to bring in the cash
in 2019 live music was the second
biggest revenue driver for the music
industry
mark mulligan a music business and
technology analyst
says it hasn't always been that way it
wasn't until we got to
the end of the 90s and throughout the
2000s when
music piracy hit the music business
at that time for every dollar lost
the live music industry gained a couple
of dollars and we saw that you know live
music thrived and became this hugely
professional business we've got now
now with the coronavirus pandemic many
in the industry fear that smaller
concert promoters and venues may be
forced to close
while others could be acquired by large
concert promoters like live nation
we saw a complete hit on the
the revenues of the big live companies
but also crucially
music artists have spent years seeing
live music as the main source of income
and that just stopped
and it's a change which is probably
going to take up to three years for us
to fully recover from
with much of the world still on pause
artists and promoters
are getting creative big names like john
legend
as well as indie artists are turning to
homespun live shows as a means to
continue
performing the versus instagram live
series of beat battles
where hip hop legends face off has
garnered over 17 million live views
but it's not replacing concerts as a
source of revenue
the vast majority of live streamed
events and virtual events as a whole at
the moment are free
and that is something that needs to be
fixed because artists need the income
they can't afford what used to be the
main income source to become a free
product in its digital domain
one way the industry is selling tickets
right now is through drive-in concerts
these shows have started popping up
around the world in denmark
germany croatia south korea and in the
united states
they're providing a way for fans to see
artists in person
from the safety of their cars but
tickets for these shows
aren't running cheap in denmark mads
langer's june drive-in concerts cost the
equivalent of 98 us dollars per car
the shows can sell up to 500 tickets
even with social discipline measures in
place you know something is you know
safe as a driving you've still got a
question of
what does it do to the live experience
itself we will see a realignment
of what live music is worth to consumers
and therefore a realignment of
what you can charge for different types
of events the pandemic has fueled
other innovations like multiplayer video
game concerts
on april 23rd more than 12 million
fortnite players attended travis scott's
10-minute virtual performance
the game's biggest event ever instead of
selling traditional tickets
their production sold merchandise and
fans could buy
in-game upgrades fortnite's developer
epic games
didn't confirm whether the event was
profitable or not
shortly after the concert they launched
a new feature called party royale where
users can virtually hang out and listen
to live sets with artists like steve
aoki
dylan francis and deadmau5 within the
next year or two not in the distant
future
we're going to see a lot more in-game
concerts some of the record labels are
already hiring people
to be able to actually program their
artists into games
the record labels are going to be seeing
it as a revenue source where they can
start
licensing their performances their their
artists much in the same way as they
license
music to streaming services mulligan
says these alternative performances can
become a lucrative avenue for the music
industry
even after the pandemic subsides and
live in-person concerts fully return
we've got brands sponsoring some live
streams we've got
some artists charging at the moment it's
nearly all free
and but we'll see the emergence of more
paid options
live streaming is going to be the thing
that people do most
games might be the one that generates
the most engagement
and the most revenue though analysts say
that this is a moment where rapid
innovation is leading the industry into
a new era
you know we'll have virtual music
concert booking agents we might have
agencies just there to make
avatars for artists appear in games so
yes it's going to be tough
yes some people are going to struggle
but we're also going to see the
emergence of a new
innovative live music industry
you